i want to ask you about uh something
else has just uh popped up here about i
mean we knew it was
uh coming uh postal workers crown post
offices are to
stage a fresh strike next monday in this
row over
pay jobs and closures and of course uh
a little bit of uh the privatization
around the corner something else of
course labour
might intervene in as well if they got
into power uh yes indeed uh
the i mean the dispute with uh post
office workers has been uh rolling off
for some time it's
predominantly won over pay and new
strike dates
have been announced as you say this
morning i mean it's intriguing because
it feeds into
the bigger picture of the way in which
the services we rely on
are being privatized and the way in
which they work in future
uh the cwu the union uh interestingly
enough dermot
is making a move in conference uh at
some point in the next half hour or so
billy hayes the leader of that union
will put to the labour conference that
if there is another labour government
it should commit to renationalizing the
royal mail
a service of course which in the coming
weeks the government has every intention
of privatising interesting times